I'm joined today by John Hargrove who's
a former senior killer whale trainer at
two SeaWorld Parks he has since left and
exposed much of what goes on in the
killer whale entertainment industry John
it's so great to talk to you how did you
first get into the world of training
whales thank you for having me
I you know ever since I was a little kid
you know I love kids since I can
remember my first memories as a child
but when I first went to a SeaWorld Park
I was six years old that was in 1980
just was completely mesmerized by the
shows and from that point forward that's
all I ever talked about that's all I
ever said I wanted to be and I often get
that from people I went to school with
this you're the only person we know that
used to say as a kid this is what I'm
going to be and you actually turned out
to you know achieve that and you were
hired as an apprentice trainer at age 20
at SeaWorld San Antonio then in 95 you
transferred to SeaWorld in California uh
can you give me a sense of for how long
or until what point did you think that
this entire world was on the up-and-up
in terms of ethics and the health of the
whales when when did you start to say oh
you know what that this maybe isn't as
good of a thing as I thought yeah I
would say probably around the four year
mark and the reason why it takes even
into four years is because in to be you
learn very quickly right away in the
beginning that it's not right for the
people that this this this perfect life
that you envisioned that you're going to
live you know happily ever after with
the whales with all your other teammates
that have the same dream and same
passion so you're all going to be this
tight-knit family you realize that is a
complete farce right away but because it
takes you so long to do things with the
animals especially with orcas it takes
years to get to the point where you
start to see
the and understand the drugs that are
being given understand the procedures
that are being performed and why they
are being performed on animals such as
like invasive procedures the the deaths
of whales and how young they were and
and then you'd have another death of
another whale and then they are so young
and then you you start hearing because
we weren't exposed to you know the
research and the data from researchers
in science mammal scientists that out in
the wild we were really shielded from
that because they didn't want us being
exposed to anything we were taught and
brought up very elitist mentality that
we are the experts and we are the only
experts on the planet and we're the ones
that know everything and everybody comes
to SeaWorld to get anything so we were
really it wasn't even discouraged we
were just completely shielded from any
any outside influence any outside
information and it was a very ominous
feeling to that if you did start to
search for other sources of information
there were consequences to you in your
career whether you were held back
you won't promote it when you would when
you would normally have been promoted if
you maybe you weren't moved to a certain
area to work with certain animals that
you wanted to work with there were
always ways that management found a way
to hang things over your head to keep
you in line and keep you the way that
they wanted to keep you yeah I mean a
couple of the some some of the big myths
that the the documentary blackfish which
you were interviewed for exposed include
this false notion that we often hear
from SeaWorld and that that had there's
documented video of being repeated on
tours that the orcas actually have
longer life spans at SeaWorld because of
the great care they receive we now know
that that's not the case we were often
told oh the dorsal fin fin flopping down
that's totally normal that happens in
the wild as well in reality it's
incredibly rare in the wild but but very
common at SeaWorld when you say that
there were sort of repercussions for
exploring other data on that uh what did
that mean I mean if you just went home
and googled some of that information and
wanted to find out about the life
expectancy of the dorsal fin or whatever
in what way did the consequences happen
well to date myself a little bit you
know I'm 42 and I left it in August of
2012 but googling you know this type of
information really didn't you know
become even possible into the early
2000s well maybe not Google but like
Alta Vista or something you know yeah it
was um we were told flat out that and
and you can paraphrase this but they use
these words and words equally offensive
but that these marine mammal scientists
and researchers that were not associated
with SeaWorld they did not share the
same views as SeaWorld were crazy people
that they were the lunatics they were
the fanatics they were the animal rights
extremists they we were mocked them we
laughed at them it was just part of the
culture I did it too because I didn't
know any better and I was a part of that
culture and you want to fit in and you
want to succeed and I had no reason at
that time to to doubt them you know so
you really just truly just blindly
believed that what they were saying to
you everything out of their mouth you
took it as gospel because why would they
lie to you which is a line that Samberg
uses in the end the film blackfish a
friend of mine and former SeaWorld
trainer and you know we just all wanted
to do that job because we love the
whales and we wanted to be happy and we
thought the whales would work also and
it was it's quite shocking as you go and
you through your career and you progress
through your career and you realize that
100 percent of captive adult male whales
and at sea
or other parks are collapsed their
dorsal fins are completely collapsed 100
percent of adult males and some of the
females and then you also learn that
like you were saying with the life
expectancy I did just for an op-ed
recently I just took the 10 most recent
years which according to SeaWorld is
their most advanced period for their
superior veterinary care which I'll get
more more about that in a second but
these whales the average life expectancy
of these animals was under the age of 13
years old they were dying on average
before the age of 13 and this was then
that the most recent 10-year period so
you know there's so many things like
that that are just absolutely ridiculous
and even when you face the world with
these cold hard facts and data it
doesn't matter where they are the forum
it doesn't matter and this is where I
was naive it doesn't matter if they're
before the California Coastal Commission
or the California State Assembly or if
they're in federal court they will
continue to lie and they stick to their
talking points and it just it's like
they they just they don't care or they
feel like if we say it enough then
eventually they'll stop asking us I
don't know what it is but it's it's
actually from a psychological standpoint
it's fascinating to watch it because you
know they'll sit there and say we don't
separate mothers from their calves and
they'll use a picture of a mother and
calf that are in completely different
countries and and then but yet they'll
still sit there and say to a member of
the assembly no we do not separate
mothers from from cab yeah
that's not true hey John down you became
an expert witness for the government in
multiple cases involving SeaWorld and
whales you have the New York Times
best-selling memoir beneath the surface
and as a result of all this SeaWorld has
tried to smear you in one of the ways
they've done this is by sort of
releasing under publicizing a video
where you're on video using the n-word
and it sort of seems to me as as
fascinating as it is whether you're
racist as a as an individual or not it
seems like that has nothing whatsoever
to do with the allegations about
SeaWorld does it absolutely and you know
and of course there's two different
issues there and one is you know I'm not
a racist but and and that word is an
ugly word and you know I take full
accountability for that video was six
years old I was completely drunk and I
was in the privacy of someone's home I
was trying to get someone to repeat a
story where that racial slur was used
but regardless it's inappropriate is
ugly that word hurts people and you
don't say it but aside from that you're
right it has nothing to do with my
killer whale training career it has
nothing to do about the facts that are
in my book and it's very ironic that the
people who did this
SeaWorld because they weren't even smart
enough to use a third party they
themselves sent it to the media and said
before you interview this guy or before
you review give his a book a review you
need to watch this video and he's a liar
and he's this when SeaWorld themselves
were found guilty not just charged or
investigated but they were found guilty
by the federal government for racial
discrimination and their hiring
practices over 1,000 times specific to
blacks and Latinos thumb is like visibly
so what I what I found really very one
of the most offensive things I found
about that it was is that they used the
black community they exploited the black
community to try to get back at me and
to try to you know to smear me and trust
me I know SeaWorld so well I mean they
created me I know this is how this is
how they work this is how they operate
so I knew they were they were going to
come with something I just didn't know
what and you know that was an illegally
reported video that you know what you
can't you can't record some point in the
privacy of their own home against their
will
and they not know about it and then six
years later over you know at the time
they released it last year was five
years but not six years and then give it
to SeaWorld and see well push it out to
all these media outlets so there's still
potential legal consequences for doing
so and if that were to happen I would
put that money back into the black
community and also for seaside
sanctuaries for orcas but um you know
just see well it's disgusting you know
in so many ways that you know this uh
this is how they operate this is how
they they shut up and silent so many
trainers and so many trainers are
fearful of them because they know they
use tactics like this I saw them do it
on many other trainers throughout my
career not that specific tactic but but
others that were equally as um you know
shocking and and in desperate it's
really a desperate move on their part
when they can't just even debate the
facts about the animals and what's
really happening they have to start
digging around into your personal life
yeah I'm trying to say look you know
look this is he's a bad person don't
like him because you know is I mean it's
so childish really John in the very
limited time we have left there was a
lot of hubbub around this announcement
that SeaWorld made not long ago that
they're ending the Orca breeding program
they're responding to what they could
describe the sort of changing public
opinion about these types of killer
whale shows and training programs real
quick what's your sense of that is there
really any value to that I mean it seems
at this point they have a number of
young whales and that they can continue
this for a long time even if they stop
the breeding program now exactly and
well first of all they knew they had to
make that announcement because they saw
the legislative writing on the wall so
to speak because we'd won a B 23:05
which is the bill that has now become
law that prevents the world from from
their captive or kab reading program and
artificial insemination so they just did
the PR move and try to get out ahead of
it must look like oh look were there
good guys we came up to the
this decision on our own no you were
forced to do that and even Joel Manby
later said in interviews that they were
forced to make that decision so you know
they haven't evolved as they they often
like to say now - they were forced
legally and you know the fact is about
as far as changing the shows goes for
these whales though whatever however the
public sees the shows whatever
window-dressing so to speak you want to
put on it you change the set you change
this you change that that's for the
public that does not affect the whales
and the concrete tanks that those whales
are living in and those tanks are from
the mid 80s suit Florida Shamu stadium
was built in 84 um California 87 and
Texas 88 Texas has had no improvement
since 1988 that's 30 years ago and yet
all these wells have made them hundreds
of millions of dollars throughout the
years and the wells never been fitted
but as far as the breeding program goes
you know right now Takara is pregnant so
I think it you know here they make this
announcement oh we're going to be the
good guys and and we're going to stop
the breeding program and stop the
artificial insemination oh yeah and by
the way one of our whales is pregnant
right now as we make this announcement
yes oh yeah you know I knew they were
going to do that to Takara - because she
was one of the most viable females for
to be used based as a baby machine
essentially but what they haven't
discussed is okay how are you going to
in to ensure that none of these wells
are going to get pregnant in the future
because if that happens we're obviously
not going to terminate the the calves
are euthanized that the calf so what
what mechanisms what protocols are you
going to have in place that are going to
make sure that now you're your because
it's a law now right because we won um
though you're going to make sure that we
know whales get pregnant that like to
car being pregnant right now that
that does not happen again and they have
not come forth with any of those uh
those protocols no down yep we've been
speaking with former senior killer whale
trainer at two SeaWorld Parks John
Hargrove his book is beneath the surface
John fascinating compelling and
obviously incredibly disturbing thanks
for sharing today thank you for having
me have a good day